well first of all congratulations
sparckella is back
i'm sure at this point in your career
you're used to maybe seeing your name in
the credits at the end of films but to
see your name on the cover of this book
also with new york times best-selling
author
definitely new
uh
i don't even you know look
all this is so new um
i don't even really know how to explain
it like i've said it in a couple
interviews like
if you interviewed every single english
teacher that i ever
i would definitely be in the bracket of
like the least likely to do anything
ever in literature or with words
i
i
they've been proud of me if i just knew
how to make a complete sentence and and
the fact that this has happened is
like it just wasn't me there's an army
behind these things and and like it just
the whole thing wouldn't be realized
without so many people and i you know
i won't bore everybody with all their
names but they all know who they are and
it's it's one of those things i love
seeing the smile on your face it's just
meaning of pride
because you have done so much in your
career so accomplished you are an actor
a filmmaker but
this is my favorite one right here
favorite role to date is being a father
because it's still happening i'm not
sure how it's going to work out
it's you know you're trying to secure
your job and be like i don't know i
don't know how it's going you know uh no
it's it
it's one of those things like you know
when people
before you have a kid
you either
don't want to have a kid or you do want
to have a kid or you don't know and then
it just happens to you and and like
you're never ready for it and it's
always going to teach you it's still
teaching me and um yeah
my little
my littles is is around here and and
like
day to day you know that you're not
going to be the coolest kid in the room
and she's going to keep you in line and
uh
i don't know what it's like to have a
have a son but i know what it's like to
have a daughter and it is
wild i've never been creatively
challenged more in my career or in my
life than just being a dad simply day to
day a girl dad i love it and i love how
much she inspires your work because so
much of this is your daughter this book
in particular sparkla makes a plan i
hear that the inspiration behind the
storyline was a special day that you
shared with your daughter building a
birdhouse yeah yeah it was one of those
like kind of just random days we we
don't do a ton of like i don't know very
cliche projects where you know we make a
lot of things we paint we
draw murals like we do all kind of
things that are creative but we never
made like something so cliche as a
birdhouse and i remember like when she
came and she just had the idea and i was
like oh no
like i was like okay she's already got
the idea of how she wants it to look how
she wants it to be painted like the
levels like you know how she wants to
hang and i was and i and i knew about at
least at least 70 percent of what she
wanted to do wasn't gonna work or we
didn't have the materials and i was just
like oh man this is gonna be a day
and uh because she's very very
strong-willed and and i remember
not having
the tools to know how to tell her
that this wasn't gonna like really be
exactly how she wanted to be so i just
kind of had to let her like go fail and
and like it was a long process
lots of frustration and uh lots of
patience and and then what we got to was
one of the cooler bird houses that i've
ever seen i don't know if birds really
want to live in it but we really really
like it and and like we haven't actually
hunted in a tree yet and we don't we
don't know if
so yeah so you got the final product and
it helped inspire hopefully the next uh
new york times bestseller too oh yeah i
mean look those things are i don't even
know yeah
thank you yeah yeah no i what i do know
what we've both learned is just how to
be with each other inside of something
that we both want to have happen and
just kind of go on the journey i love
how down you are for all of the fun you
rock sparkly tutus the headbands painted
nails full face of makeup now is your
daughter all for the fun shenanigans or
is she kind of getting to an age where
like maybe a little embarrassed how does
she feel
we haven't got to the embarrassed stage
just yet um thankfully because that was
my like it was kind of truly my only way
in uh the only reason i started wearing
the tutus and painting the nails and
wearing the face paint and stuff because
it was just me going into her world
whatever the stuff that she liked i just
was like i don't know like that was me
that was my only way in like i
obviously not a girl i definitely didn't
grow up like evie's growing up and i
just kind of tried to
do whatever i visually saw to kind of
not stick out in her world as like not a
thing that she wanted to be there
and and so far
we're getting along how much fun are you
having tapping into your own inner child
because i watched the clip of you doing
the audiobook and i was laughing with
you when you were really tapping into
your inner child yeah
one i love audiobooks like i
love them more than i can possibly say i
actually geeked out when i was just like
doing like the intro macmillan audio
presents
the one and only sparkla makes a plan
written and read by channing tatum
illustrated by kim barnes
[Music]
how was that we're done guys that was
that was great right cool all right it
was like a weird experience that i had
of like projecting myself in
the first time i was in a movie i was
like oh my god i'm about to be in a
movie about to do the thing
uh
but
you know this walk with being a dad
being like there's no words to kind of
try to explain what it all is like i
have so many feelings and less words to
be able to really like try to articulate
how i feel
um
i know that things are
kind of changing you know and that's
kind of where i'm at right now like
she's about to start going into like the
tween like age and you know i'm kind of
looking back on like all the all the
moments savoring them yeah you're just
like oh wow like and you go we barely in
your mind like survive those but it's
not the truth like you know you actually
thrived during them and now we're going
into a different place and it's uh i
don't know it's just it's it's more of a
beautiful feeling than it does me able
to explain what i really got out of it
that's it
there's no there's no way to like tell
people what being a parent is because
what what you experience along the way
is so educational that it's so
beyond the scope of like of of really
being able to explain what that gives
you like and and like you can only kind
of do it like by being a parent and i
love that you get to keep
the fun rolling and keep being that
inner child because sparkla is coming to
the big screen hopefully we'll see
movies oh man movies movies have a long
long long life
uh but we definitely have we definitely
have a great idea i love like 80s and
90s movies i love like straight cartoon
sort of kids movies
but what i've missed in the last maybe
like two decades is
the like
live action like putting actual kids
like in to like return to oz or or these
these movies where it makes a real
fantastical world and and like the kids
get to actually go inside of that world
and or where the kids go get to go in
but they actually take their parents and
they have to basically grow and learn
something together and
and um that's our intention so far we'll
see how it goes
because everything changes when you make
a movie like you can't know is this
gonna be a role where we see you
hopefully in a way that we've never seen
you before uh i guess i've never played
well i played a dad before but i've
never played this kind of dad um and
i've never played a dad that that uh is
so close to like how i you know i am in
real life and who knows if i'll be like
i am in real life in the movie just yet
there's so much uh to be
kind of discovered you know you you
really go on a journey of
you have an intention and you sort of
march in that direction and you just
sort of like oh this feels a little like
more right today so it's a discovery how
do you and jenna feel about maybe your
daughter following in your acting
footsteps one day uh
she can be a she can be an actress if
she wants to be um
i think that i feel very uh very adamant
about i don't want her to be an actress
until she's 18.
um
for me i really believe that i want her
to go and have life
and experience life
and not try to because like acting you
really have to kind of get outside of
yourself and really look at like who you
are what you are
i don't know if you know what that is
until you're like way older or even like
able to do that properly um until you're
way older and and it's not to say that
there aren't some incredible like kid
actors out there you know like joseph
gordon-levitt is like
like one of my greatest friends and i
don't know how he's become
the the human that he is like going
through his his whole trajectory of like
being a child actor and like being an
incredible child
i i don't know if um i would want that
that navigational sort of you know
circumstance for for abby um i just
wanted to go be a person a human and if
she's really interested in acting and
and like movies and stories
she'll find it she'll find it um but not
right now it's also a lot of work i mean
look at you you had two big theatrical
films this year that's amazing yeah i
mean i i've been around for a while so
yeah i'm just trying to trying to come
back and do some stuff really quickly
how much fun did you have with salma
soma came in like just was a like a tour
de force like uh
she made everyone work harder on set
like
when i say
from writer to director to me she she
asked everybody the hard questions of
why are you doing this like what's going
on like
why are we here right now and
i there is not a question in my mind of
why she is who she is and she's done
what she's done and she's gonna keep
like i think just just blowing people's
minds of what there are no bounds when
you're that much of a um
you're you're just
you don't stop at
one answer you know you don't stop it
just like okay
she's she's ever gonna be digging to
like what's more of the truth and that's
rad um i will do any movie with her
forever
[Music]